today I'm going to give you the
step-by-step process that I used to get
an amazing 40 dollars per hour what
development job working from home
part-time with no degree very little
experience and no connections at the age
of 19 not only that but this
step-by-step process got like five to
ten other offers from other companies
and a full time offer at the company I'm
working at right now so that means if I
were to have accepted that full-time
offer at $40 per hour I would have been
making over 80k per year at the age of
19 but if you want to know why I didn't
accept that offer and leave it in the
comments down below and I can definitely
make a view on that too but the great
thing is is that anyone can replicate my
results and you don't need to be the
best programmer in the world because I
definitely wasn't at that time so if
you're looking to get your first gig
maybe you're in college or maybe you're
teaching yourself right now this is a
super important video so make sure you
watch to the very end and hit that
subscribe button so you don't miss out
on any other videos just like this and
on other topics as well three times a
week as always my name is Jake Trent and
let's get into it so quick background I
still work at this job right now
part-time and I really enjoy it
they give me a really creative projects
to work on they just send me the designs
and I basically just implement the front
end I work whenever I want I just
tracked my hours and at the end of the
month I just send them an invoice and
they send me a check that people are
really great and easy to work with and
overall it's just a really low
maintenance relationship I got this job
after I finished my second year of
computer science at a community college
and no you definitely don't need to be
in college for this to work for you
either if you want to know more about
what it's actually like working day by
day as a remote web developer in this
specific scenario give the video a
thumbs up so that I know that you guys
want more videos just like this so yeah
it's a really great job for someone my
age with my experience level and yeah
let's get into low steps so step number
one is to have a personal project to
show off your skills I believe that this
step is the most crucial thing that
contributed to my success because think
about it from an employer standpoint
you're coming in with little to no
experience so how are they gonna know
that you can actually do the work and
you're not just like wasting their time
the answer
is a well-developed personal project so
not only does a personal project really
show off what you can do on your skills
it also shows employers like other
things that they always look for number
one is that it shows them that you're
actually passionate about what
development or whatever like niche that
you're going for otherwise you wouldn't
have invested so much time into a
personal project unless you really
enjoyed coding it shows that you can
work on your own because in order to
make that personal project you have to
do it with no supervision and you know
have enough responsibility to actually
follow it through and finish it so funny
story for the interview for this $40 per
hour job I actually like really botched
the interview and did like absolutely
horribly but they ended up giving me the
job anyways and I think it was because
you know what developers are so intimate
and on top of that the personal project
really had them like get past that
horrible interview and because of those
two factors I believe that's why they
gave me that job even at the rate that I
requested so what was the personal
project it was a software-as-a-service
web app built on flask a Python web
framework called beautiful stocks and
the whole idea behind it was it helps
technical stock traders to trade more
efficiently by automating some of their
charting analysis you know when they
look at charts to figure out like when a
buy and sell and then why like certain
parameters are met it gives them a
little dirt based on a custom alert that
the trader makes I know it sounds kind
of complicated but it honestly wasn't
too bad and you really don't need to go
this big to have like a really good
personal project if you want to check
out what it looks like I linked it below
even though I'm not supporting the app
anymore I still have it running because
you know I just think it's cool but if
you're interested in building something
similar to list like a
software-as-a-service app for your own
personal project or just for fun or like
I asked an actual business I linked to
the really amazing course I took down
below and it really gave me like a solid
code base to work and build my app off
of plus like that extractor Nick he was
super supportive too like he answers
your questions like within 24 hours most
of the time I think it was like 50 bucks
or something like that and it's
definitely worth every single penny and
Nick if you're watching this thanks for
an amazing course so yeah build a
personal project to make sure it looks
professional
if it looks like [ __ ] that's how the
employer thinks you're gonna code on
their team number two is the half a
resume that really stands out and this
is a pretty basic one but especially
with big companies you know they're
going through like hundreds of resumes
at a time so you definitely don't want
one that blends in use one of the
pre-made themes on Microsoft Word at
unlink to your personal project as some
details about it add some social proof
in the form of like quotes from
recommendations from past employers
teachers etc and yeah the last thing you
want is to hand type it on a blank
boring document and use like generic
business jargon a good rule of thumb is
the more specific your resume is to the
employer that you're applying for the
better here's my resume that I used to
get my job and if you want a copy of it
to base yours off of I'm going to link
it below and it's basically like a name
your price thing where you just name how
much you think it's worth to you this is
just a way to make sure that anyone who
actually gets it you know they're
actually gonna put it to use because
otherwise you you know you'll be wasting
your money number three is the mass
apply this is pretty much where all the
magic happens but you needed those two
first steps to really set yourself up
for success in this stage so now you
have an awesome resume a project to show
off and stand out from the crowd now
it's time to get your name out there so
here's what not to do apply to like five
positions I'm gonna get this point and
then complain when
you don't get a job and say [ __ ] like a
job murder sucks or people don't hire
people without experience and blah blah
blah
no BMW so how many applications should
you send it really depends but in my
situation to get those ten interviews I
set out around 200 to 300 applications
now you may be wondering you know to the
300 applications that's gonna take
forever but I've a solution to that to
really speed things up and Plus think
about this way if you know that five out
of every 100 applications are gonna get
a response
the quicker you get to setting up a
hundred applications the quicker you get
to getting those five responses and
getting your dream job so instead of
just dreading rejection where you don't
hear back from an application you send
out treat it as a side that you're just
one step closer to getting the job that
you love all right so the two main sites
that I'd use were LinkedIn and Angel
list they're playing other sites to use
but those were the two that I use you
can use whatever you want but that's
what we're gonna base our example off of
today the great thing about both of them
is they have a quick apply feature which
is gonna like speed things up like super
super dramatically and we're gonna use
that to our benefit so let's start on
linked end just gonna LinkedIn I'm gonna
assume that you have an account already
for this example I'm gonna search for
web developer and jobs from here I'm
gonna go to all filters and then you can
do whatever you want just make sure you
click on easy apply anything else it's
really up to you I'll click apply so
yeah over 1,100 result and a belief if
you just search developer instead of web
developer you're gonna get like around
like 10,000 or something like that so
from here it's pretty simple all you
have to do is go down the list and click
easy apply so when you do that so just
make sure your contact information is
correct the first time you do it it will
save all your presets for the next time
and then make sure you upload your
resume to and then answer these
questions and then click Submit I'm not
going to but you guys get the point and
then literally from here you just go
down the list and click easy apply click
apply click apply and now hopefully you
see that it's not gonna take too long to
get through a hundred two hundred maybe
even a thousand
I look fairly future the car company
interesting alright now let's go to
AngelList so type in angel Coe same
thing I'm gonna assume you have an
account if not make one this one really
pay attention to how you like set up
your account or your profile to look
because they don't have they you don't
upload a resume here it's just people
just see your profile so yeah from here
let's go to jobs and then I just great
get rid of all this stuff I'll just
search like developer for now over
19,000 startups with what development
jobs so I don't know about you but if
you can't find a job that you like out
like nineteen thousand nineteen thousand
listings I don't know what to tell you
so yeah same thing here again make sure
your profile is all set up and good to
go because employers that's all they see
sometimes if you click apply sometimes
you get like one or two questions you
have to answer but that's it
so click apply go down a list if you
like what you see click apply and then
ya get through as many as you can or as
many as you want
so if you have followed every single
step so far there is no reason why you
shouldn't have a few interviews lined up
for the next few weeks and once that
happens maybe you have a few interviews
a few job offers maybe you actually take
a job let me know in the comments
because I would love to see that that
would make my day and you'll motivate
others a lot as well too and this is
your first time here and you found this
video at all helpful be sure to smash
that subscribe button the big red button
below just click it it only takes a
second it's completely free give the
video a thumbs up as well turn the bail
notification so you don't miss out on
any other future videos thank you so
much for watching stay persistent and I
will see you guys in the next one